[Música]
un cordial saludo a todos ustedes nos
estamos reuniendo aquí en el estudio 26
de radio canadá para presentarles este
programa semanal canalda en las américas
café antiguamente el castor mensajero y
más recientemente también el castor
cibernético de hoy 27 28 de febrero del
2020 y en vivo y en directo por facebook
live youtube de nuestro sitio internet y
nuestra aplicación y hoy este programa
es un programa como están viendo ya
ustedes en la cámara un programa
especial estamos luciendo un una
camiseta que muchos de ustedes ya
conocen y a lo mejor estarán envidiosos
de vernos con esa camiseta pero
este programa de hoy está dedicado
exclusivamente totalmente al 75
aniversario de radio canadá
internacional que fue el martes pasado
el martes 25 de febrero y bueno pues
entonces decidimos que lo íbamos a
celebrar aquí hoy en vivo y en directo
con todos ustedes en este programa
semanal así que 75 años que comenzaron
en la onda corta y que desde el 25 desde
el 24 de junio del 2012
nos despedimos de la onda corta y
empezamos a transmitir por internet por
la web hoy en los estudios me acompañan
jessica chávez leonardo gimeno y luis
laborda bienvenida y bienvenidos que tal
buenas tardes gracias y también se
encuentra acá en el estudio como se han
podido dar cuenta al otro lado de la
mesa se encuentra se encuentra héctor
moreno un ex colega de la onda corta de
radio canadá internacional y que nos
acompaña hoy en este programa especial
de los 75 años
héctor bienvenido muchas gracias estoy
muy contento de estar aquí en esta
emisión especial de los 75 años de radio
canadá internacional ahora será canal
internacional porque radio y otro
personaje que ustedes también muchos de
ustedes ya deben ya deben conocer
se trata de otro colega otro ex colega
de radio canadá internacionales la onda
corta se trata de martín movilla
empezó aquí en radio canadá
internacional y que ahora está volando
en otros cielos ya hablaremos de eso
pero sigue siendo sigue siendo el eje de
la onda eso sí la onda corta sigue
estando en el corazón aunque ya exista
poco pablo como es algo a los compañeros
queridos a todos los oyentes y a las
personas que nos escuchan un placer
estar aquí y bien y yo quería decir con
respecto a jessica que es de la nueva
colega del servicio latinoamericano de
radio canadá internacional que está
colaborando con nosotros desde este año
más o menos y bueno pues entonces te
quería dar la bienvenida oficial acá en
este equipo muy masculino de hecho por
el momento las mujeres que están fuera
del estudio y bueno
primero que todo y antes que todo un
caluroso saludo a todos ustedes allá del
otro lado del micrófono y de las cámaras
y muchísimas gracias por estar con
nosotros
este programa tan particular como ya lo
habíamos anunciado la semana pasada el
castor cibernético
está dedicado al 75 aniversario de este
de radio canadá internacional y vamos a
entrar de lleno vamos a entrar de lleno
con este programa especial pero antes y
para ponernos a tono leo tenemos moral
un mensaje no tenemos no uno varios
mensajes ya la gente empieza a sumarse
david your es ya están mirándonos y nos
dice felices 75 aniversario queridos
amigos y a david hay que hacerle un
monumento a todo porque porque ha
contribuido mucho con este festejo nos
ha enviado un montón de las cosas que
usted van a ver
hoy en nuestro programa david iglesia es
el que se encargó de hacer el esfuerzo
de concretar un montón de estos saludos
que van a ser parte de esta emisión del
día del acto oyentes y radios
internacionales que nos enviaron
mensajes de felicitación y que vamos a
pasar aquí en este problema exacto juan
carlos miranda duarte dice felicidades
tommy castro dice mil felicidades
jonathan rivas también nos manda
y marvin nos está viendo también marvin
también alguna vez ha colaborado quizás
no como su profesión que periodista pero
te ha colaborado con un radio cadena
nacional bueno y también tenemos un
mensaje muy particular de un viejo
oyente de radio canadá internacional y
vamos a escuchar ese mensaje
hola amigos de radio canadá
internacional soy hugo long y de rosario
argentina quizás me extraña en un
poquito porque hace un tiempo que no
escribo pero soy oyente de muchísimo
tiempo y bueno en este momento que
ustedes están cumpliendo 75 años quería
saludarlos yo hace más o menos 30 que
soy oyente y buenos recuerdos viejas
épocas
-este antiguos locutores susana penales
peña de puga
héctor moreno la gran león ahora qué
me leyó mi primer carta qué emoción en
aquel momento guillermo y bueno los de
ahora pablo es de palomas
giné las que me llamo o alguna vez para
hacerme alguna entrevista por tantos
momentos recuerdo si quería nada
participar de este programa especial y
la verdad que decirles que sigan
mostrando o canadá al mundo y bueno un
abrazo muy grande a la distancia y ojalá
algún día pueda visitarlos y
abrazarlos en persona un cariño grande
muchísimas gracias
colombi como deseo como escucha sector
hay quiénes te recuerdan todavía
[Risas]
cualquiera que te fuiste pensionado
y yo me fui en el 2002 a vivir tengo 18
años ya de estar fuera estas estas
historias de la radio pablo son muy
chistosas yo recuerdo cuando yo era
muchacho joven en colombia y escuchaba
de vez en cuando a la radio
internacional y escuchaba radio canadá
internacional y me acuerdo de escucharte
en la época y abajo muy chistoso cuando
ya espero trabajaba aquí conocí a héctor
personalmente sedes como como curioso es
es un lazo de la onda corta de algo que
yo escuchaba en mi país cuando era un
muchacho cuando ponía la onda corta en
las noches escuchar los programas de
jersey y después venir a conocer a las
mismas personas es todo un proceso y así
yo supongo por el tiempo que hacíamos
contestación a la correspondencia o
después con eso volvió el castor
etcétera la gente tiene un lazo con él
con el programa él tiene un lazo con la
radio y un lazo que se vuelve eterno no
que se vuelve para siempre que se
acuerda de cada nombre como estábamos
escuchando a nuestro amigo long a hugo
por el nombre propio a una hora brava su
primer mensaje al aire se lo leyó leonor
a jackman
si es esa precisión y esos recuerdos son
bonitos 75 años más tarde aquí en este
estudio que lo estamos celebrando hoy
algo que debe ser completamente
diferente y nuevo para ti héctor es un
entorno que tú no conocía yo decía ya no
es radio canadá internacional vaqueros
de radio no tiene nada yo empecé cuando
era radio nada más funda corta e
inclusive fui a visitar las antenas que
están en nueva broadway en el norte más
norte del quebec
que le llama antenas de cortina y
demolieron que ya tumbaron y ya no
existen porque ya no existe ya confirmó
la noticia ya no ya las tumbaron bueno
pues sí mala noticia porque será muy
bonito ver todo eso
radio y ahora pues veo que todo ese
informático y todo el numérico y además
estamos con imagen ahora que los que no
conocían a héctor moreno pues la voz
esto y cómo llegaste tú el radio canadá
internacional en qué año pues bueno pues
es una larga historia y hagamos la
historia
[Risas]
como te decía hace rato que veníamos
para el estudio este edificio que ella
desde dentro de poco lo va a ser
obsoleto yo lo conocí nuevo pero conocí
el anterior a éste todavía
la prehistoria casi de radio canadá y yo
llegué aquí en quebec en montreal en los
años 70 en 71 exactamente y lo primero
que fui a dirigirme a la radio canadá
internacional que estaba en esta misma
calle nada más que más al oeste ahora yo
no sé si existe el edificio en un
edificio o gris
piedra antigua y allí conocí a el
director me presenté y me presento al
staff de aquel entonces y estaba don
jorge juan rodríguez el jefe entonces yo
me presenté y evidentemente en ese
tiempo no había plazas me dice bueno
posiblemente va a haber plazas en un
buen día no yo nada más conocía al señor
rodríguez
algunos años después ya cuando me iba a
volver a méxico mi país natal
vine a visitarlos y entonces rodríguez
el jefe que ya era más jefe diría hay
algo para ti ahora y me presentó a josé
barrios pepín pepín mi entrañable amigo
que fue mi compañero y amigo durante
diez quince años y ahí empezó empecé
como pista no creía en mí dice mira
hacemos esto después del bus y si ni
siquiera me miró mi currículum vite y se
nos si tú puedes hacer lo haces y si no
pues ya no y así encontré esa es la
respuesta mira la vida como son las
coincidencias dos en este caso en lo que
respecta a ti en lo que respecta a pepín
yo conocí a pepín por allá en el 75
en la casa española que es un
restaurante que está en la calle
serán cerca de sherbrooke y bueno ahí
conocí a pepín y me habló de radio
canadá internacional es bueno entonces
pues que eso quedó así y años más tarde
cuando me interese un poco más en la
radio y quise venir aquí a esta casa fue
con héctor moreno justamente fue el
primer mi primer colega él fue el que me
contrató para trabajar aquí en esa época
tú eras el director de programas
grabados creo que era cuando se hacían
en discos y en el especie en dispuesto
que ya no existen prácticamente
problemas volviendo a la moda al tálamo
dosis y entonces eso así fue no que
decíamos que fue fue una época muy
simpática y ni fue la primera persona de
radio canadá internacional con la que yo
estuve en contacto efectivamente porque
había 22 secciones en el internacional
en español
programas grabados se hacían en disco o
en techos después en cinta y el lugar
radio en directo y yo estaba en el
equipo de pepín que era el que hacía los
programas grabados entonces yo me ocupe
de hacer los discos que se enviaban a
las estaciones de radio locales de todos
los países de américa latina y que ahí
es sobre todo las radios universitarias
las reproducían entonces como éramos dos
teníamos que buscar material y entonces
había mucha gente que llegaba y lo
contratamos como pistas es decir a la
pieza y hacían cada uno un topo
un reportaje una entrevista lo que sea y
se les pagaba con un recuerdo eso y yo
tomé exactamente el mismo modelo de
pepín cuanto llegaban de cualquier país
que llegaran yo no veía a su currículum
vite yo les decía c estoy estoy yo si
eres capaz de hacerlo lo haces si se te
paga y si no y así muchos se auto
eliminaron y eliminado por capacidad
[Música]
pero por culpa de imagen yo pues
entonces me fui en un momento dado pero
volví a reaparecer años más tarde
martín win que año llegué hasta radio
canadá internacional en mayo del año
yo cuando llevaba estaba cumpliendo
cuatro años de haber llegado a canadá de
hecho llegué aquí en el año 2000 y fue
una cosa muy curiosa porque yo sabía que
existiera de canadá internacional pero
digamos que yo salí de colombia por unas
condiciones muy particulares de
problemas de seguridad dónde yo era
periodista y después es muy difícil el
exilio como tal y parece mentira pero no
como que pierda en algún momento el
norte uno no sabe hacia dónde va el
objetivo es como regresar se a casa y
que de hecho es una de las cosas que yo
descubrí descubrí cuando recién llegué
más que quede descubierto y es que
muchas veces cuando uno es exiliado le
pasa a mucha gente los países que llegan
aquí como chile argentina américa
central es que vive uno con una pierna
ya hay otra acá no es más de trabajo en
la cama pero al final no es ni de allá
ni de acá entonces hay que hacer todo un
proceso para poner los dos pies en un
solo lado y decidir que va a continuar
ni existía ni limonada esto sí yo me
acuerdo yo trabajé en una organización
no gubernamental y en ese proceso
trabajar con una organización no
gubernamental vine una vez aquí a radio
canadá internacional con unos personajes
organizamos un tribunal internacional de
opinión sobre el tema de los indígenas
mayas en guatemala y la época
y toda esta cosa estoy vino gente varias
partes del mundo se es un evento y yo
era el coordinador del evento me
contrataron para eso y vine aquí y
conocía el equipo de radio canadá
internacional a pablo a leonor a ruffo a
paloma que ya estaba en el equipo en ese
momento y se dio simplemente una
relación que fue con vos fué contigo fue
con pablo y abrieron un concurso para
reemplazar a susana peña de puga que yo
conocía en ese momento y se coincidió en
ese y tú me mandaste que había un
concurso que salió en la prensa etcétera
y yo me presenté yo no lo hice realmente
empezar the comedian a escoger a digamos
que como que me presenté porque era una
opción que había que explorar y de esa
manera entre ellos radio canadá
internacional me presentó concurso me
escogieran es muy curioso porque la gran
mayoría de ustedes entraban siendo
villista es decir trabajando a la pieza
como reemplazantes y terminan siendo
permanentes yo entré a radio canadá
internacional como permanente que a mi
primer puesto aquí fuego permanente yo
nunca hice reemplazos nunca hice trabajo
a la pieza sino yo entré como permanente
a reemplazar a susana peña en 2004 bueno
ya que estuvimos juntos hasta el 2012
hubo la debacle internacional de radio
rumbo la onda corta y pues yo era
permanente pero se eliminaron puestos y
me sacaron de radio canadá internacional
lo cual me obligó pablo a re convertirme
en otras cosas bueno volver a lo tuyo
final volvió era la única dama colombia
hacía televisión y ahora en este momento
estás acá con la casa matriz con radio
canadá trabajando en la televisión
efectivamente se tratan de la emisión de
investigación ya hace varios años y
bueno nada me tocó cómo volver a hacer
lo que sabía hacer de alguna forma y
tratar de volver a retomar pero fue una
experiencia de radio canadá
internacional es un mundo maravilloso no
sólo por por lo que uno hace como
periodista es por descubrir a la gente
cómo no acordarse de las cartas que
llegaban semanales de cuba donde la
gente le hablaba a uno como un amigo
como no acordarse de los amigos con los
que se ponían bravos
cómo era que se llamaba pablo nuestro
amigo el profesor doctor
juan el cubano que se ponía a brabo y
nos regañaba y de pronto nos amaba y de
pronto que murió hace algunos años que
fue te escucha de lo que se llama mente
pero escribe a cada semana como no
acordarte de eso como no acordarse de la
gente de argentina en colombia la gente
que nos escribía cosas como gracias a
ustedes durante la dictadura en mi país
yo pude estar informado con el mundo así
que no crece como ser humano en radio
canadá internacional
yo participe el mismo concurso pero él
ganó
[Risas]
en el 2004 me presenté el mismo concurso
que se presentó él pero yo no gané pero
por otro lado porque cuando llegue
cuando yo llegué a canadá líneas en los
trámites aquí el centro de montreal
íbamos en el auto me distraía mi hermano
mi cuñada y luego a la parte de atrás y
dije eso es radio canadá sí sí es el
edificio matriz de radio canadá en
montreal ahí voy a trabajarlo
quiero añadir que meritorio porque yo
supe yo ya no estaba aquí pero supe que
ese los concursos para un puesto eran
muy muy difíciles yo vi 12 en los 25
años que yo trabajé y cuando
efectivamente nos fuimos 2 héctor
gutierrez equipo cayó y yo había una
plaza y esa plaza se puso a concurso y
yo me enteré que había como 200 personas
que habían aplicado
el ritmo son muy serios esos concursos
habías ganado entonces yo no te felicite
pero te felicito radio centre ville
estaba haciendo la noticia en radio
centre ville y menos encontré a otro
colega que se fue con usted moreno
el otro vector
y él me dijo tendría que presentar
y me dijo también representante yo le
hice caso me presenté y martín me ganó
[Risas]
yo quiero bueno agradecíamos ahorita
nuestro amigo david grecia pero antes tú
tienes algo y le tengo mensajes acá
jonathan rivas dice radio oyente desde
niño a gamba que bien javier gonzález
nunca dice quiero compartir con ustedes
mi deseo para todos en este 75
universidad de ahora de 40 nacional
saludos a todos los presentes en la mesa
felix león dice sí pero venga en verano
no sé quién les respondía está feliz
león este donde no nos dice no dice
dónde es gustavo luque dice hola desde
mis vacaciones recorriendo una isla como
fortaleza cerca florianápolis en santa
catarina en brasil
javier conéctate con este gustavo que
hay una sorpresa javier gonzález en un
garage dice al señor héctor ya martín
conocía nada más que su voz así que me
sorprendo hoy viendo los bonitos
recuerdos de la onda corta paloma
también está chequeando este programa
césar rodríguez charlize en saludo a los
antiguos y los nuevos de radio con
internacional larga vida a altas antenas
y bandas anchas para la emisora
canadiense gustavo luque dice creo que
el apellido del oyente cubano es socio
y si escocia consigo cierro consigo
cierra el nombre de rafael con cierre de
firmas de cartas del señor profesor
doctor sierra y era inteligente
agradable para lo martínez y le mando un
abrazo los estoy viendo colegas y amigos
no nos felicitó y felicitó a todos
nuestros seguidores y sofía dice saludos
desde halifax bueno muy bien gracias
paloma gracias a la única felicitación y
bueno hablábamos entonces de david
grecia que hizo un esfuerzo yo diría
fantástico y para conseguir todos los
mensajes que vamos a pasar hoy entonces
vamos a escuchar el de él
[Música]
estas cuatro notas de o canadá y las
identificaciones en inglés y francés son
sonidos que añoramos y que viven en los
corazones de cada uno de los oyentes que
provenimos de los gloriosos años de la
onda corta
afortunadamente el servicio en español
de radio canadá internacional sigue
existiendo y canadá en las américas café
con el castor cibernético siguen siendo
nuestro punto de encuentro entre el país
de la bandera con la hoja de arce y
latinoamérica
queridos pablo leonora rufo paloma louis
y leonardo les deseo un muy feliz 75
aniversario de las emisiones de rci y un
venturoso futuro por venir desde
argentina su agente david grecia a
brindar y a seguir bailando con la
comida del castor
muchísimas gracias david un saludo y un
agradecimiento inmenso por todo el
esfuerzo que has hecho tú
particularmente en la realización de
este programa con todas las personas que
contactan test muchísimas gracias y
tenemos también fotos hay una antigua
colega no colega radioescuchas
radio canadá internacional que nos envió
la siguiente foto pier
admira feliz aniversario radio canadá
internacional
miriam no hay camiseta para los más
viejitos que se fue
no no son muy gordos revolviendo cajas y
cajas y cajas encontramos 5
mientras tamaño medio y pequeño yo me
puse una y parecía el capitán américa
con el traje encogido así que no me
preguntaste luís como llegó a radio
canadá internacional
[Risas]
porque había una necesidad de reemplazo
de algún
un integrante del equipo de ese momento
y empecé como contábamos a la vieja
usanza digamos haciendo reemplazos sin
presentar currículum sin pasar por
ningún examen ni por ningún concurso
solamente haciendo tareas que le
encargaban a uno en el momento y desde
entonces aunque parezca mentira ya hace
15 años salvo una interrupción luego de
los recortes producidos en 2012 que me
facilitaron conocer otros países
[Risas]
es la llegada de nuestro querido oro y
la guarda tenemos también a luis por ahí
mensajes no mensajes vídeos sí señor
vamos a escucharlos a los mensajes que
vos me decías que decir nos ponemos a
las personas ante la nombramos después
ya qué
los ríos
en las personas después saludó inmenso
para ustedes
bueno aparentemente tenemos un problema
con nuestro vídeo o vídeo como dirían
los argentinos que es un vídeo por eso
no funciona
mientras tanto tú leonardo entonces tú
tu primer intento fue esa vez que martín
ti te arrebató el puesto pues exacto ese
fue mi primer intento y después pone en
este caso fue paloma y leonor a las que
cuando estábamos trabajando trabajamos
juntos con martín en un proyecto en
español aquí en montreal que era nuevo
mundo televisión en ese momento yo hacía
las noticias en nuevo mundo martín hacia
el segmento de radio canadá
internacional era un segmento del
estadio así que compartimos bueno y
entablamos una amistad con martín y al
mismo tiempo entramos en contacto con
todo el equipo de red de plan
internacional que el tiempo fue paloma
la que
estaba por tomar vacaciones entonces
pidió que hacía falta alguien para
reemplazos y empecé a reemplazarlo a
partir de todo el reemplazo porque en
este momento el equipo era bastante
grande tan ginela estaba diego cree go
en nicolás entró un poquito después
porque empezó a colaborar ustedes
llegaron después de que salió también
alguien que se nos olvida gabriela
gabriela mayor mallorquín que son
entraban y con los reemplazos que abrió
con ella compartir con gabriela
compartir yo estaba en el mismo tiempo
si hacíamos reemplazo juntos
y después bueno se abrió la parte del
web se empezó a crecer la parte del web
y fue ahí donde yo tomé la otra vía y
gracias a la internet todavía estoy aquí
compartiendo con ustedes bueno
fantástico así vamos a pasar esos vídeos
que no de felicitación que nos han
llegado
en español en argentina al mundo hecho
de cerrar
al exterior que queremos mandar un
saludo inmenso para ustedes
de ese radio canadá internacional en sus
75 años nosotros hace muy poquitos días
cumplimos 62 años en nuestros servicios
y estamos en este escándalo también al
igual que es un saludo inmenso desde
aquí desde rae radiodifusión argentina
al exterior
vuelvo a repetir nuestro servicio en
español para todo el mundo
ah
hay situaciones
más
kiko wright
por el cálamo todo
hay situaciones juntos
[Música]
queremos enviar los 6.75 nos gustan
todos como habrás andar y la capital
federal la republicación quiera y no se
la gana
deseo de darle a los otros
pero ya no
internacional
llegará en que castilla ahora mismo
maria
[Música]
andersen de bersuit
col y col quieren buenos aires en
internación regir cualquier buenos aires
a raíz de imágenes y un circuito de
break o argentina en york poner un
mínimo y responde a happy valley y feliz
cumpleaños a radio canadá entre nación
bueno eso fue bueno casi todas las
lenguas de radio pasaron acá delante de
su cámara para felicitarlos
yo creo que entendí todo salvo el
japonés como que no estaba deseando
feliz cumpleaños con mucho más que los
demás pero pero los nombres de las
personas que comieron y venderán los
colegas de ra el servicio de red y
fusión argentina el exterior que existe
también desde hace añares 62
los conozco desde que tenían la vieja
sede en la calle ayacucho y avenida las
heras antes de mudarse a la calle maipú
555 de hasta ahora estás a trabajar con
argentina y en el aire explicó pueda de
que la que orlando farías del equipo en
inglés
julieta galván del equipo en portugués
gustavo ríos en español y marcelo
hallada y caritina cápsulas en italiano
y para decirles que en el radio
argentina de exterior transmite en
español alemán francés inglés italiano
portugués y chino
así que faltaron esas lenguas
[Risas]
bueno pues seguimos entonces aquí
celebrando este 75 aniversario de radio
ganada internacional y así que tenemos
más mensajes sí exactamente tenemos
mensajes audio audios que nos llegan de
eslovaquia vamos a escuchar el primero
bien
radio eslovaquia internacional
[Música]
el equipo de radio suba que
internacional felicita de corazón a
radio canadá internacional por sus 75
cumpleaños
enhorabuena llegará aquí en jessica era
duda uso de vic iba de radio eslovaquia
internacional que nos deseaba feliz
cumpleaños entonces muchas gracias a
lara tenemos otro mensaje
[Música]
desde radio exterior de españa desde la
casa de la radio en madrid quiero
felicitar al radio canadá internacional
por sus 75 años una felicitación para
sus trabajadores y para los oyentes que
durante este tiempo han establecido y
establecen una relación especial un
hecho comunicativo que va más allá de
una conexión material y que sintoniza
con las sensaciones y emociones que
mutuamente se generan en estos 75 años
de historia de radio canadá
internacional han cambiado muchas cosas
no solo en esta emisora sino en todas
las que tenemos un ámbito mayor más
global como es también radio exterior de
españa los hábitos de escucha y los
intereses de los oyentes son diferentes
pero la radio sabe adaptarse a los
nuevos tiempos sin abandonar a un
público tradicional así paso a paso año
tras año emisoras como radio canadá
internacional han llegado a cumplir 75
años reiteró las felicitaciones a todos
oyentes y trabajadores
y espero y deseo que cumplamos muchos
años más felicidades
[Música]
a todo el equipo de radio canadá
internacional queremos transmitirles
nuestras sinceras felicitaciones por su
75º aniversario nuestros deseos para que
siga creciendo y dando lo mejor en el
mundo de la radiodifusión internacional
les desea andrea one y song jong
presentadoras del programa el cartero de
radio taiwán internacional
pastor exactamente entonces ese mensaje
que no los había mandado desde taiwán
desde radio internacional de taiwán
gracias a andrea one y azul son muy bien
y nosotros que tenemos nuevas
participaciones
sofía nos decía saludos de halifax y
abajo y se contraten me hay que venir a
hacer la prueba empezar a trabajar
esperemos miriam alarcón dice david
hermoso y emocionante saludo hugo bbc
dice me uno común yo había leído coreano
más no es castor ya no más a la
celebración de nuestro de nuestra radio
canal internacional daniel pérez o brezo
dice saludos desde lima pero recuerdo
que les escuchaba a través de la onda
corta y mira melancon dice qué lindo
escuchar a sol y andrea así que saludos
y gracias a toda la gente que nos ha
mandado saludos y a toda la gente que
está con nosotros viviendo y reviviendo
estos mensajes muy bien y tenemos un
mensaje
mensaje vídeo de un top fans de radio
canadá internacional y se trata de
gustavo lucas veamos ese mensaje
[Música]
ahora nos ha gustado algunas tardes mi
nombre es gustavo lucas oyentes de radio
canal internacional de la ciudad de melo
el departamento de sol largo en uruguay
aunque en esta ocasión en el parque beto
carrero world
cerca a la ciudad de florianópolis
estado de santa catarina en brasil
compartir alguna experiencia de radio
canadá internacional
ya que estoy en brasil a recordar el
programa portugués conducido por el
terminar
pero también en dos ocasiones cuando
pude hablar por teléfono
con pablo gómez barrios en una
oportunidad en esta oportunidad con
stefan bajan del programa en francés
simplemente quiero recordar eso y mandar
un saludo y mejores deseos a radio canal
internacional es 65 años
muchísimas gracias gustavo y que
participe el escuchar prácticamente
todos los problemas del árabe y el chino
pero también ya los escuchan no
entienden mucho permite que no está
siempre pegado a la onda de radio cara
internacional y al sitio de internet
entonces tiene la el toque especial de
saber qué pasa en cada una de las
secciones así que siempre está pegadito
no participa y bueno yo quiero leer acá
un mensaje que nos llegó el audio y
desafortunadamente un formato que no
pudimos bajar se trata de nuestros
amigos y colegas de radio nederland
alfonso montealegre y jaime báguena que
nos seguían vivos y nos envían un
cordial saludo y felicitaciones por el
75 aniversario desde gilberzon en
holanda alfonso en su mensaje nos
recuerda su paso por los estudios del
entonces kart castor mensajero
donde de radio canadá internacional
donde hicimos un programa conjunto esa
vez con radio nederland que fue muy
apreciado hicimos incluso una q sl
específica para ese programa que
difundimos acá en radio canadá
internacional y ellos también allá a sus
oyentes en inversión y bueno entonces
alfonso y jaime nos desean un feliz 75
aniversario y desde acá desde montreal
les enviamos a nosotros un fuerte abrazo
muchísimas gracias y bueno seguimos
entonces acá a ver con nuestros
invitados martín no yo quiero pronto una
cosa a héctor ahora que estabas hablando
de tecnologías y todo esto yo me
pregunto para una persona que durante
tantos años estuvo en varias partes del
mundo de alguna manera con la cinta con
todas estas cosas que se mandaban al
mundo con la participación el 6 que es
lo que más te hace falta de esa época en
la que estabas en radio canadá
internacional que es lo que más daño
horas que es lo que lo que más te
hubiese gustado de pronto
otra vez hacer bueno hay dos cosas en
primer lugar yo creo que en todas las
esferas de la actividad humana cuando
uno deja de trabajar lo primero que es
sus compañeros sus camaradas
a corto o largo plazo bueno eso me faltó
mucho segundo lugar del otro lado las
cartas no teníamos el potencia todo en
directo no llegaban pilas y pilas pero
grandes pilas de cartas de todas partes
del mundo principalmente de cuba y
llegando todavía recibimos todavía eso
me falta mucho porque en el contacto
humano yo sabía que no se escuchaba
porque no se escuchaba que cuales eran
sus inquietudes de esas partes del mundo
y me hacía jolie
pues no la ilusión pero me hacían digo
como quien ese problema esto como tienen
problemas acá como tiene ese problema y
aún por las mismas cartas como escribía
me daba cuenta qué clase de persona era
eso me falta y desde luego como te digo
es el contacto humano y el contacto con
los estudios los micrófonos y todo eso
es muy bonito cuando pablo me dijo que
si venía hoy yo en realidad yo acabo de
sacar una cosa
visión al aire y estaba súper pensé que
no iba a poder venir y hacer una versión
web de esta historia que sacamos ayer
sobre un tema canadiense con compañías
mineras y fue ha sido muchísimo trabajo
pero vine porque yo creo que hay un
momento en el que uno en la vida siempre
tiene que agradecer los pasos que ha
dado y radio canadá internacional fue un
paso agradable cuando uno habla una
persona como tú que eres como de los que
estamos aquí en el decano de los que el
veterano de los castigos de aquí uno
dice han evolucionado muchas cosas pero
yo creo que lo que me hace falta bien lo
mismo es lo mismo es el contacto con la
gente el imaginarse uno cuando la gente
le contaba cosas yo leí cartas aquí
donde la gente le contaba uno su vida
personal donde la gente le contaba a uno
la vida del país donde la gente se
desahogaba y contaba cosas contra un
gobierno o que contaba simplemente la
belleza de una playa o la belleza de un
páramo es tan rico que que no puede uno
no pensar en que por más que uno está
haciendo otra cosa en donde yo estoy
ahora no recibo cartas de los gente y
cuando llegan a la mente son negativas
porque es un programa investigación hay
mucha gente lo critica uno no le gusta
honestamente eso era viajar por el mundo
era viajar por el mundo cuando uno podía
leer una carta de cuba' de argentina de
colombia de gente que nos quería de
europa también era la imaginación la que
volaba y eso parece muy bonito creo que
ese es una de las cosas lindas que se
perdió con la con la caída de la onda
corta en el mundo porque no solo fue
radio canadá internacional y es el hecho
de que ese contacto humano que sea a
través de una onda a veces cuando no le
escuchaba que entraba que no entraba
marcó mucha genera tirado el vídeo
porque para el público la ley
exactamente lo mismo el público también
se sentía en contacto con otra parte del
planeta que no conocía e imaginaba como
vos decías en este caso como será por
ejemplo canadá gente que nunca puso el
pie aquí se preguntaba qué sería de este
país y al estar en contacto con gente de
radio canadá se sentía parte de ese
territorio que en persona aún no había
podido conocer ese proceso de
imaginación se daba creo yo por doble
vía como le pasaba a uno con empezó
escuchar onda corta en la infancia en mi
caso no específicamente el radio canal
internacional pero sí desde muy pequeño
recuerdo escuchar no sé por qué con
muchas
en emisiones de radio habana cuba y
sobre todo de radio moscú de la vieja
radio moscú con aquellas voces
soviéticas que nos hablaban desde muy
lejos eso fue lo que te hizo lo que
empujó años más tarde a lo que vaya a
trabajar no no eso a eso me empujaron
los recortes en falta
pero además esa época la radio antigua
también eran las voces de la voz de
américa latina por ejemplo tenía el
modelo del locutor locutor que
generalmente el locutor con la gran voz
no sé que vos pero el doctor gutiérrez
exactamente pero las radios
internacionales no lo respetaban
necesariamente el modelo de que la voz
tenía que ser pero lo que había era una
voz agradable que transmitía
conocimiento además por lo que dice luis
cuando ustedes iban al aire presentaba
la canadá al mundo contaban historias
ese es el recuerdo que yo tengo de
muchacho en colombia que ustedes hablan
de los años 70s porque no trabajaba
así por esos años entonces pero sí era
muy lindo escuchar en la radio en onda
corta las historias ese recuerdo que yo
tengo de tu voz es una historia contada
es como cuando un abuelo lo sienta uno
en las piernas y le cuenta algo eso era
la radio internacional un contacto con
la imaginación como dice luis un
contacto con el amor por algo por
alguien hay gente que ama canadá gracias
a radio canal internacional
que ha venido aquí y sabe más de canadá
que los canadienses bueno también puedo
añadir que ese era la otra la otra parte
que que me estimulaba a mí a hablar de
canadá porque yo en los viajes que hice
américa latina me di cuenta que no
conocían mucho de canadá y me
preguntaban cosas como de la nieve como
de la separación de que ve como de asco
pero elementales entonces es pertinente
que nosotros debemos conocer lo que es
canadá y cómo como se produce en canadá
y lo que son las claves nos empeñamos
con mucho esmero a transmitir esa
información luego hay algún caso nos
está acabando el tiempo rápidamente así
que terminé javier gonzález nunca dice
yo creo que se rompe el rating del
programa felicidades bendiciones a todo
el panel muchas felicitaciones pablo un
abrazo dice rafael bandera pacheco y
miriam alarcón dice sigan festejando
hermoso el programa de hoy
felicitaciones y bueno
desafortunadamente el tiempo pasa como
agua entre los dedos ese fue todo el
tiempo del que disponíamos para este
programa especial
cibernético en los controles técnicos
leo wieland pierre louis y el
insustituible
cumplió años el cumpleaños de luis
laborda leonardo jessica chávez héctor
moreno en martín movilla gracias y bueno
yo por mi parte les deseo un agradable
fin de semana y bueno pues que se
diviertan pues porque ya es fin de
semana y hay que divertirse hasta la
próxima otros 65 años más a radio canadá
internacional
[Música]
ah
i
[Música]